I'm Paul Kennedy welcome to ideas
Aristotle claimed happiness was the
ultimate purpose of life mathematician
and philosopher Blaise Pascal believed
that all men seek happiness the poet
Alexander Pope enthused Oh happiness our
beings end and a praising the virtue of
happiness is both timeless and kindly go
to your local bookstore and you'll find
shelves packed with titles like the art
of happiness authentic happiness the
howl of happiness the happiness
advantage to name just a few newspapers
and popular magazines regularly
published scientific studies touting the
benefits of happiness happy people enjoy
greater capacity for intimacy in
relationships happiness increases your
physical mental and emotional health
happiness makes you more creative with
all that happiness has going for it who
doesn't want more of it as one expert in
the science of happiness put it it is
the holy grail of life everyone wants
happiness cbc producer frank Falk isn't
so sure in this hour of ideas Frank
questions our culture's obsession with
happiness and wonders if it's time to
cool our hot pursuit of it here's his
documentary say no to happiness
let me make one thing perfectly clear I
am NOT nor have I ever been a crewman at
least not a committed one I like feeling
good I try to maintain an optimistic
outlook preferring to walk on the sunny
side of the street but am I a happy
person to quote the English poet William
Blake joy and woe are woven fine I can
tell you that's more of a mantra for me
then don't worry be happy but to be fair
having done some looking into this whole
business around happiness I know that no
one is suggesting that striving for
happiness is about ignoring the woes of
life and being cheerful 24/7 what I do
know is that what is meant by happiness
is rather elusive sure Aristotle talked
about the importance of happiness but
what he meant by happiness had to do
with living a life of virtue achieving
the golden mean a life lived in balance
something like what a surfer achieves
when catching the perfect wave the fact
is philosophers theologians and
scientists have failed to come up with a
definition of happiness that will make
everyone well happy
well it's absolutely true that happiness
is a very elusive concept I started my
career as a lawyer and I spent a
semester arguing about the definition of
a contract and happiness is even more
hard to pin down there's something like
15 academic definitions of happiness
Gretchen Rubin is the author of the
bestseller the Happiness Project in
which she details her year of trying to
achieve greater happiness in her life
for me sort of coming to it as a lay
person the looseness of the term
happiness wasn't a problem and in fact
was sort of an advantage because it
could encompass a lot of different
things and different people might
emphasize different qualities within
happiness for some people it's more
about peace and some people meaning some
people satisfaction some serenity some
mindfulness people emphasize different
aspects of it and I really weed I didn't
have to agree with everyone else and
what was really important for me was not
to arrive at some perfect definition of
happiness but really to say to myself
well how could I be happier whatever it
is to be happy what can I do to be
happier next week next month so I sort
of took the dodge of justice Potter
Stewart who said of obscenity I know it
when I see it and I decided that for me
I knew what it meant to be happier and I
didn't really have to get all tangled up
in the precise definitions that are
required if you're going to do certain
kinds of examinations of the subject
Gretchen got the idea to devote a year
to being happier while stuck on a bus in
the pouring rain
not exactly a situation that inspires
positive moods as it turns out it
afforded her one of those rare moments
for self reflection in which she
wondered what do I want from life
anyway and what Gretchen realized she
wanted was to be happier not that she
was unhappy she had a good marriage two
small children she adored and was
completing a book on John F Kennedy what
I meant by wanting to be happier was
that I I felt that I needed to
appreciate my life more I felt like time
was passing so quickly
and I wanted to grab onto it I wanted to
appreciate it I didn't want to take it
for granted I have a phrase that I often
say to myself
the days are long but the years are
short I wanted to ask more of myself I
wanted to be a better mother I wanted to
be a better wife I wanted to be a better
friend I wanted to be a better writer I
wanted to be a better citizen I wanted
to expect more for myself and I thought
about the qualities that I wanted and
it's yeah I wanted to be feel more
creative and more lighthearted and more
calm and more patient and have more
forbearance and less be less judgmental
less naggy and I wanted to bring my life
more into harmony with my values and
it's funny I don't think I really
understood that very well at the
beginning that was the kind that was one
of the major major things that I learned
as I went on is that was what was so
important was that my life reflect my
values my temperament my interests that
I could only build a happy life on the
foundation of my own nature
Gretchen realized that if she was going
to tackle a project of this size she
needed a plan so she created a chart the
chart was divided into the twelve months
of the year
each month had a theme for example the
theme for January was boost energy
February remember love March aim higher
and so on and for each month she made a
list of daily resolutions so under
June's theme of make time for friendship
her resolutions were remember birthdays
be generous don't gossip make new
friends every night Gretchen would put a
checkmark by a resolution indicating
that she had managed to keep it that day
having a chart helped Gretchen to
achieve her monthly goals but seven
months into her project the pursuit of
happiness got stalled I hit a low point
in my happiness project where I felt
like I was making no progress I was
tired of my way of thinking I wasn't
tired of the subject of happiness which
I have never failed to find fascinating
but I was
part of my way of thinking about it you
know just like every time you go to buy
clothes you buy the same black sweater
that you always bought before I just
felt like my thoughts were stuck in a
groove I felt that I was backsliding in
all the usual ways and one of the things
is when you think a lot about how you
want to be better it makes you much more
aware of what you're doing wrong so for
example I didn't think I gossip very
much but when I decided that I was going
to stop altogether I realized how often
I did so I was much more aware of all
the things that I was doing that I knew
were contrary to my happiness but I was
doing anyway and one of the things that
came from my happiness project is I just
have this long bag of things that I do
to try to get through it so it's things
like go to bed early call a friend go
outside in the sunlight get some
exercise do a good deed for someone else
one of the best ways to self-medicate I
did all these things and eventually I
came out of it but I think it's natural
to just go through these periods where
you just feel blue and that wasn't in
for any particular reason but then of
course naturally we all have periods for
a very specific reason we're feeling
very unhappy so I think one of the
things about a Happiness Project is
sometimes it's not possible to be happy
it's just not realistic you're just not
in a happy time of life it's not you're
not happy but I think what I learned was
there's there's things that you can do
to try to be as happy as you can be
under the circumstances and that kind of
gives you the armor that you need to
deal with a difficult situation like any
smart person planning a long trip
Gretchen did lots of research and
preparation for her year-long journey
many of the ideas she used to help her
deal with the difficult times king from
the emerging science of positive
psychology positive psychology is really
about the scientific understanding of
what makes a life most worth living what
are the conditions that lead to that and
then most importantly what are the
strategies that we can use to help
people move a little bit closer between
where they presently are and where
ideally they'd like to be Todd cashton
is associate professor of psychology at
George Mason University in Virginia
an author of designing positive
psychology a book on the science of
well-being he is also a self-described
provocateur in the field of positive
psychology the more that you actually
take a gauge of how happy you are or
assess how happy you are or think about
reflect on am I happy right now
the more that you do that the less happy
you become and it becomes quickly we're
talking about four times a day you think
about am I happy you're less light
you're actually show decrements in your
happiness and the reason for that is
we're leaving the present moment so no
longer are we in the present and being
open and receptive we're constantly
deciding is what I'm feeling and
thinking about now fit with being happy
there's a lot of well-meaning people who
are studying happiness but are not
skeptical I don't take things at face
value I'm a scientist I want where's the
data where's the evidence
mindfulness there's this cultural
obsession about taking this
philosophical and ancient teachings
about mindfulness which is fantastic but
then the question is is it always
adaptive to be mindful
and the answer to as to most absolute
statements is no is it's very
resource-intensive to be mindful to
focus with great profound awareness and
attention consumes energy if you think
about emergency medical technicians
going on the scene for some for a crime
scene or someone that's bloodied and has
maybe you know hours to potentially live
needs to be brought to a hospital there
is research to show that being mindless
and reflexively using their skills to
get the job done right then and there is
more adaptive than being mindful so
being a provocateur is about bending
over backwards to disapprove ideas to
find out the truth and unravel some of
the mysteries of human nature as opposed
to blindly accepting things on faith
because they fit with what I'd like
things to look like what concerns me
with the current obsession with
happiness is that under the rubric of
happiness all sorts of things that
aren't really related are often
discussed so for example their claims
that happy people are healthier actually
the research doesn't precisely indicate
that what it indicates is that people
who have less negative emotion are
healthier and we don't exactly know the
direction of causality
I mean negative emotion is a dimension
in and of itself and people who are high
negative emotion tend to be depressed
and anxious and depression is associated
with increased production of a stress
hormone cortisol and that seems to have
very negative consequences over time it
impairs your immune system and makes you
more susceptible to obesity and
depression and cancer and heart disease
but technically that's a negative
emotion issue
Jordan Peterson is a clinical
psychologist and teaches at the
University of Toronto he lectures on
topics such as the nature of self
deception the role of neuroscience and
human behavior the quest for meaning and
purpose in life the claim is often made
the happy people are more creative and
the evidence for that again is very weak
there are a few studies that indicate
that if you put people in a state of
positive mood that they can think in a
more Korea
manner briefly but the bulk of the
personality evidence suggests that
creative people are somewhat
disagreeable and that they're high in a
trait called openness and openness is a
measure of fluidity of thought and it
appears to be fundamentally unrelated to
happiness it might be objected
I suppose that the right response to
negative situations is to consider how
they might be made better and I would
agree with that but the problem is is
that making things better and being
happy are not the same thing unless you
decide by definition that they're the
same thing in which case I don't believe
that you're speaking within the
scientific realm because you're not
allowed to put vastly differing
phenomena in the same box and call them
the same if you're a scientist you can
do that normal conversation and so for
example if someone's suffering from a
terrible illness you might determine
that aiding them would be an appropriate
thing to do and you might also consider
that that would make you feel better but
to call that the pursuit of happiness is
merely to be very unclear about the
distinction between compassion and joy
and given the state of psychological
science at this point there's absolutely
no excuse for failing to make that
distinction but you see I've dodged that
by saying my happiness project is my
happiness and so the fact that there
might be multiple definitions or sub
topics within happiness that are somehow
separable I think that you get further
in terms of thinking about how to be
happier if you just throw it all into
one big basket rather than trying to
tease out the difference between
compassion and happiness of course a big
question in a Happiness Project with
your setting out to be happier is well
how are you going to know if you're
happy or how are you going to measure
yourself and and I have a friend he's a
scientist and he was very very focused
on this his idea was that I should have
my husband score me every morning and
night on a one to ten scale and I was
said look that would definitely not add
to the happiness in my household because
there is no way my husband is going to
be sitting around scoring me morning and
night and I didn't even really think
that that was a very productive exercise
to do I just didn't approach it very
I said to myself I want to be happier
whatever that means whatever the
looseness of the term happiness and
happier mean and if I think I'm happier
I am happier
and calving come to the end of it and
having continued to live with the
consequences of it because because I
continue to do all my resolutions and
many many more resolutions so my
Happiness Project is really something
that I think I'll do for the rest of my
life
it's just indisputable to me and I think
anybody who's around me would say that
I'm absolutely happier the atmosphere of
my household is let more lighthearted
and more calm it seems like we have more
time but it's not like we're doing
anything less it feels more rich but
also more simple I don't have a chart
that like shows me ticking upward I
don't have vials of blood showing how my
hormone levels have changed but I
definitely feel confident saying that I
did make myself happier
Gretchen's quest for happiness inspired
and continues to inspire others to
create their own happiness projects
which explains why her book has been on
bestseller lists since first hitting the
market in 2009 Gretchen's most important
piece of advice for those wanting to
follow her example is this regardless of
how you might define happiness for
yourself making happiness the primary
goal in your life is going to help you
achieve it there's a long tradition of
people arguing that you shouldn't aim
directly at happiness and that a
happiness is something that's a
byproduct of a life well-lived or a life
directed at other aims and that you
should and if you aim at being happy you
sort of will fort yourself or trip over
your own feet or somehow be pursuing the
wrong goals that won't bring you to a
happy life and in my own experience I
really think that you're much more
likely to hit a target if you aim at it
and I found for myself that when I said
to myself am I happy how could I be
happier
I almost instantly did become happier
just because asking myself that question
made me appreciate more of what elements
of happiness I already did have in my
life things that I was taking for
granted or being distracted from and it
also helped me see places where I could
make changes that were not hard buddy
happiness has sort of a surprisingly bad
reputation and I got a lot of criticism
from people when I when I was saying
that I was doing a Happiness Project
that I was trying to make myself happier
I was talking to a journalist who
clearly spot that this is a very very
selfish complacent spoiled bratty
undertaking and he was somebody who
spent a lot of time doing kind of
foreign reporting so he was very aware
of the suffering of the world and he
really felt like this was very morally
questionable for me to do I was very
naturally taken aback by that but I had
done a lot of thinking about it because
it is something that that you worry
about when you're thinking about
happiness is I did say to myself is this
very selfish is it morally inappropriate
to be thinking about happiness when
there's so much suffering in the world
I'd been thinking about it sort of but
it wasn't until he really gave me that
withering look of disgust that I really
focused on how did I what did I think
about the pursuit of happiness did I
feel like this was laudable and what I
found is that in my experience people
who are happy in their own lives they
have the emotional wherewithal to turn
outward and to think about the pain of
the world and they're more able to
intervene effectively because Woodmoor
unhappy we tend to be isolated and
defensive and preoccupied with our own
problems and so it's not the case that
happiness makes people complacent or
self-satisfied or preoccupied with their
own pleasure
in fact happiness kind of energizes
people to turn outward professor Todd
cache them focusing on happiness trying
to improve people's happiness writing
books about happiness this is a big
money-making industry and while I'm
critical of it I recognize that this
opens the doors for people to think
about how they can improve their lives
their relationships and the way that
they're operating in this world which
might be suboptimal and so a Gretchen
Rubin who's a good friend of mine she's
dealing with how to create optimal
conditions for human beings and she's
focusing on multiple pathways of getting
there she's focusing on multiple ways of
setting goals meeting your goals
deriving benefits just from devoting
effort much less whether you even
achieve your goals and I think this it's
important to get the dialog going and so
if it ends up being that happiness is
the Gateway for having people think
about ways that they can intentionally
improve their own lives and lives of
other people it's a great thing but what
ends up happening is this nebulous
wastebasket term where happiness is
pretty much everything that's good in
life if we focus on happiness as a
synonym for the good life or a synonym
for a well lived life we miss out on so
many facets so many nuances of what it
means to be human and it beeped full
capacity
creativity spirituality meaning and
purpose in life compassion self
compassion a sense of accomplishment a
sense of belonging a sense of autonomy
these things are not synonymous with
happiness and there are plenty of happy
people that are not creative that are
not spiritual that are not mindful and
so using a wastebasket term to capture
all of the beauties and complexities of
human behavior is extremely problematic
and it trivializes just how amazing and
how complicated it is to navigate our
social world
I've said that some people will tell you
that the purpose of life is to be happy
and those people are idiots and was a
bit of a rough statement but I what I
meant by that it was actually inspired
by a statement by Alexander Solzhenitsyn
who was the great critic of the Soviet
prison system and he commented that
happiness is something that's done in by
the first harsh blow that reality deals
you and I believe this to be the case
there there are many circumstances in
life where happiness is not only the
wrong response but also where the
expectation of happiness as a response
will put you the person attempting to be
happy and absolutely the wrong
psychological state to be prepared for
what must be done
people are built so to speak to
experience a very wide range of
motivational and emotional states that
only bear a tenuous relationship to one
another and the reason for that is that
the environment that human beings
inhabit is so complex that our
adaptation depends on a variety of very
finely differentiated responses and so
there is a time to be compassionate and
there's a time to be aggressive and
there's a time to be in pain and there's
a time to be anxious and there's a time
to be joyous and a time to be satisfied
and the healthy and well adapted person
has a very wide range of finely
differentiated responses which cannot be
boiled down to a single dimension say
happiness versus unhappiness life is not
that simple and if it was we'd only have
one emotional system happiness all it is
is it's a barometer it's just dr. Phil
101 dr. Phil always asks how are things
working for you and if you say things
are working well that's pretty that's
pretty much what we mean by happiness
happiness does not propel us forward so
it's very weird to make this the
objective of your life and what I mean
by that is while I loved being a father
I will tell you point blank with my wife
listening that it has not improved my
happiness meaning and purpose in life
through the roof happiness I was much
happier as a 30 year
having a lot of time with friends and a
lot of time to travel and a lot of time
to basically do whatever the hell that I
wanted to so in terms of my happiness
it's detracted from are there moments of
the most profound pleasure of the most
profound spirituality that I would die
for these sacred vessels that I have my
life absolutely but that's not happiness
that's spirituality to me is striving
for the sacred and the sacred is things
that you would be willing to die for
would I die for a sense of satisfaction
in my life no what would I be willing to
take the bullet over my kids absolutely
making happiness the focal point of your
life trivializes your experiences
because in order to regard anything as
truly important you also have to regard
its loss as truly meaningful and that
means that to open yourself up to
experiences of deep meaning also
simultaneously means that you have to
open yourself up to the possibility of
deep hurt and sorrow
and you do that anytime for example that
you make a relationship profound you put
your emotions on the line and that has
to be real or the relationship can't be
real and to hope that that sort of risk
could be obliterated by the indulgence
in a simplistic form of happiness is to
shrink I think in cowardice from the
demands that real human existence place
on people this is ideas in Canada on CBC
Radio one across North America on Sirius
satellite radio channel 159 and around
the world on CBC CA I'm Paul Kennedy
you're listening to CBC producer Frank
Fox say no to happiness the renowned
psychiatrist and concentration camp
survivor Victor Frankel wrote what man
actually needs is not a tensionless
state but rather the striving and
struggling for a worthwhile goal a
freely chosen task there's much wisdom
in the words of Nietzsche he who has a
why to live for can bear almost anyhow
we now return to Frank's documentary say
no to happiness
at every moment we're surrounded by what
we know and can understand but outside
of that we're surrounded by all the
things that we do not know and cannot
understand and that can manifest
themselves at any moment so we're like
small islands of tentative certainty in
a massive sea of uncertainty and
ignorance
that's our existential condition it's
really our environment even from a
scientific perspective it's the
environment that we've emerged into and
have adapted to and we have to take that
into account when we deal with our lives
because that's the truest nature of our
life it's order in the midst of infinite
chaos the human problem is how to make
sense out of the constant interplay
between that tentative order and that
infinite chaos
Jordan Peterson is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
he is also the author of maps of meaning
the architecture of belief his book
explores how religious and mythological
stories shed light on our existential
predicament and in turn can provide a
sense of meaning and purpose in the Old
Testament in in Genesis it's one of the
most profound ideas ever expressed the
Old Testament God in Genesis generates
order out of chaos and upon doing so he
states man and woman are made in my
image what does he mean by that well he
dignifies the human soul with that
statement but the attribution of dignity
is based on a psychological and and an
ontological reality and that reality is
that what the individual consciousness
confronts is equivalent in some sense to
the chaos that God originally turned
into order at the beginning of time in
that what you confront moment to moment
is the potential of being that's what
consciousness does it takes unformed
potential and makes it manifest and each
human being has the choice about which
direction that potential will manifest
itself in but not about whether or not
that manifestation will take place
because it takes place no matter what
and that's why the moral obligation of
existence is incumbent on our being
existence implies coexistence to be is
to be involved with the life of others
we delude ourselves if we think that
we're simply innocent by standards in
life being is never neutral what we do
matters you can be a creator of things
positive or you can be a creator of
things negative or you can be a creator
who abdicates their responsibility but
in all three situations you are
participating in the process that turns
chaos into order and there is no
escaping that when the high school kids
that showed up Columbine wrote about
their philosophy and the most telling
aspect of their philosophy was their
judgment of existence they'd and they
did you can read this on the net their
conclusion at the great age of 19 was
that the tragedy of existence was such
that being itself was corrupt that
because people suffered and because the
world was a dangerous and terrible place
that being itself should be eradicated
and this is a very common judgment it's
far more common than people think
and once you forego the luxury of
deciding in a sense to hell with
everything that that everything is so
corrupt that it's unredeemable once you
forego that luxury then it becomes
incumbent on you to try to work for the
betterment of being and that requires
faith and the reason it requires faith
is because a you don't know if being can
be better and B you don't know if you're
the creature to do it but the peculiar
thing is is that you will never find out
if being can be bettered or if you're
the creature to do it until you assume
that it can be bettered and you assume
that you are the creature to do it
critics of religious thinking believe
that what faith means is the Willing
to suspend rational judgment and swallow
any old thing no matter how absurd and
that's not what faith means at all what
faith means is the willingness to put
yourself on the line in pursuit of those
things that you find deeply meaningful
and that's why so many great
philosophers such as Soren Kierkegaard
emphasized above all the role that faith
plays I'm a clinical psychologist I have
an active practice 20 clients and I see
them weekly and I must professor
psychology at the University of Toronto
and so it might be surprising that I use
religious language but it's not
surprising because as soon as you start
to talk about the deepest meanings of
life the language that is most
appropriate is immediately religious and
the reason for that is that religion is
precisely that element of human
existence that deals with the most
profound elements of human being I
believe that the reason for this is this
in some sense human existence is so
contradictory that it's in a manner
technically impossible we're limited
creatures and we face unlimited
catastrophe in in that everything we
know will disappear and everyone we love
will die and so that makes existence
human existence in the sense
existentially impossible but the
religious impulse combats that in a
sense because the religious impulse
opens up to the human being the
possibility that there is sufficient
absolute within to serve as an antidote
to the absolute without and the notion
that it's necessary to have an
individual relationship with the
absolute with God for example is a
statement of the fact that we are in
fact adapted to the nature of reality
and if we draw on everything that is
within ourselves without fear then we
can develop the sorts of personalities
that are powerful enough to confront
the horrible absolute and to consider
that justifiable and worthwhile I want
to put in a good word coming from the
Jewish tradition a good word for
happiness it's it's it's striking to me
that the very first word in the first
verse of the first chapter of the Book
of Psalms it is a word that is probably
best translated as happy so it says in
Psalms happy is the one who does not
stand in the way of the wicked or walk
with sinners or sit in the company of
mockers but whose delight is in the law
of the Lord in God's law does he
meditate day and night happiness is I
think not a bad thing it's certainly
better than its opposite but but clearly
it is inadequate as a goal for our lives
if that's all that we can aspire to then
our lives do become trivial then they
become insignificant the happiest
creature in the world I think is a
lizard sitting in the Sun and if all we
want to be are lizards sitting in the
Sun it won't work for us because we have
an awareness that lizards don't have we
have an awareness that there is
something greater than ourselves greater
than our material corporeal being that
there is the infinite Dan polish is the
author of talking about God exploring
the meaning of religious life with
character guard Buber Tillich and
Heschel in his book polish explores how
each of these thinkers understand the
human encounter with the infinite the
Danish Christian philosopher søren
kierkegaard coined the term
ank's or anxiety to describe our
experience as limited beings overwhelmed
by the infinite Paul Tillich a Christian
theologian talked about the courage to
be in the face of our existential
predicament the Jewish theologian Martin
Buber talked about the importance of
holding ourselves open to the
unconditional mystery that we encounter
in every sphere of our life Rabbi
Abraham Joshua Heschel spoke of knowing
life has ultimate meaning though we can
never fully comprehend that
meaning only sense it all of them could
be characterized is existentialist
thinkers by which I mean that they like
other existentialists recognize that
this Shakespeare said there's more in
heaven and earth and there is in your
philosophy a ratio they don't focus on
creating theories they know that the
mind can go only so far so they don't
start with theory they start with with
human experience it religiously that
means that they are less interested in
talking about what God is then they're
talking about how we human beings
respond to God rather than trying to
define that which they recognize
ultimately is beyond the capacity for
human beings to either define or even
understand and that unless we find a way
of living constructively with the
infinite living in the infinite unless
we find the courage to have faith in
that which we cannot begin to understand
to begin to articulate then we're then
we're going to suffer what Kierkegaard
called acts were going to suffer that
anxiety Kierkegaard by all accounts was
not a happy fellow he suffered a major
romantic disappointment as a young man
and eventually retreated into a solitary
life of study and writing when it came
to achieving happiness in this life he
didn't believe it was possible the best
we can do is aspire to diminish the
angst that defines human existence as
for the other three they who lived in
the 20th century that that I've written
about heschel Buber Tillich all three of
them knew a great deal of suffering in
their lives so that the idea of
happiness being something paramount I
think would look ridiculous to them all
three of them were forced to leave
Germany and Europe when it fell under
Nazi domination Heschel of course came
to the United States before the full
horrors of the Nazi reality acted itself
out in Europe he was living in
Cincinnati Ohio when he got word that
his whole family had been exterminated
my guess is that anybody whose life is
shaped as his was by that experience but
really not take the notion of happiness
as the goal of life very seriously and
in his book on the profits he says quote
the world is dark and human agony is
excruciating
this is not the the writings of somebody
who could understand human life in terms
of what we're calling happiness here
it's something strange that I've
observed with my students is that when I
state the proposition to them clearly
that life is suffering and that the
purpose of life is not happiness they
actually experience that as a great
relief and the reason I believe that
they experience it as great relief is
they already know it you know even if
they wouldn't necessarily articulate
that their experience has taught them
that life is complex and tragic and
difficult and the problem with the
public portrayal of the ideal state of
humaneness as happiness is that it makes
all of these people these young people
feel ashamed of their own suffering they
feel that if they're suffering and if
they find their life tragic in its
essence that that means that there's
something wrong with them and instantly
that makes it impossible for them to
communicate anything real about their
own tragedy one of the great spiritual
geniuses of all humanity was the Buddha
and the Buddha came to an understanding
that he can talk about human life in
terms of Four Noble Truths and the first
of the Noble Truths is that all of life
is dukkha which we which we can
translate as suffering the Buddha is
teaching us that the essence of the
human experience is to suffer that
suffering is not some unfortunate thing
that that disrupts an otherwise perfect
existence or that suffering is you know
an accident that may befall some people
the Buddha is teaching that suffering is
at the heart of being a human and so it
appears to me that the price we pay for
being is suffering and then the issue
there and I believe that this is what
the greater religious traditions of the
world have been attempting to elucidate
is that the purpose of life given that
is to identify and and follow a mode of
being that makes life justifiable even
given the radical necessity of suffering
if you are constantly in a state of
placidity satisfaction and happiness
then nothing is going to affect you
deeply enough not your own suffering not
the suffering of other people not in
justice not knocked the horrors of the
world nothing is going to affect you
deeply enough so that you'll become deep
and life without depth is by definition
shallow and meaningless and there's a
problem that's associated with that
because life is tragic and because life
involves suffering if your philosophy is
shallow and meaningless when you suffer
you'll become resentful and hostile and
self-critical and then you'll become
cruel and destructive and so not only is
the there are a necessity for your own
mental health to forthrightly confront
the deepest questions of life but if you
don't then you remain a danger to
yourself and maybe more importantly to
others the suffering that we experience
is something that we can use as the
well-known image of the grain of sand
that finds its way into the shell of an
oyster and out of that discomfort the
oyster fashions the pearl the Ox the
Kierkegaard talks about can become the
inspiration for us to live in ways that
transcend simple selfishness simple
egocentricity simple focusing on
ourselves Reinhold Niebuhr who was
actually a very close friend of Hershel
said that life has no meaning except in
terms of responsibility I'm sure he sure
would have would shake his head
absolutely
one of Heschl's earliest books is called
the image of God in this world humanity
human beings are God's image in this
world our goal in life is very clear to
be in this world what we would want God
to be in this world for us through our
actions and our behaviors and our
engagements to manifest God in the world
to be radically discontent with the
things that exist in this world to be
radically discontent with the social
evils that we see around us to do what
we can to write them because we are
God's own self is it were in this world
which Ashwood say means where we finally
become the most human
I've gotten very interested in the
psychology of morality because we be
often push it aside to just religious
teachings religious ideas and when we're
making moral decisions on a daily basis
and it makes me think of exemplars of
people that have profound meaning a
purpose in life but are probably average
to a below-average
unhappiness and Martin Luther King
happens to be a real great example of
this Todd cashton is associate professor
of psychology at George Mason University
in Virginia he is the author of
designing positive psychology a book on
the science of well-being
professor cashton regularly gives talks
and workshops on how to live a
worthwhile and meaningful life this is
someone in context who had extreme
righteous indignation this is this is
just a manifestation of anger of the
mistreatment of other of other fellow
human beings on the lack of equality and
fairness these are fundamental moral
principles and his life was devoted to
this if you're talking about pursuing
goals that are outside the parameters of
happiness look to Martin Luther King the
idea of absorbing the blows the hatred
the prejudice the discrimination for
other people to make a point that these
these behaviors are not indicative of
what a good society is built on and
Martin Luther King is not the only
person he just happens to be a public
exemplar you have people in schools
right here in DC where I'm sitting right
now who are devoting themselves and
inner-city kids you've got teachers that
are creating a safe space for them a
place where they can actually learn and
grow and become a moral outstanding
citizen we're talking about people that
are taking time away from their own
happiness to do something that really
matters and but lead to a sense of
morality meaning and purpose in life
the
just don't fit on the same spectrum now
there are multiple pathways to living a
good life and I think a better approach
than having happiness as the ultimate
end point is to do things you care about
we're not talking about happiness we're
talking about engagement we're talking
about meaningful pursuits
nothing can drive you to find the
deepest meanings of life without first
realizing the absolute fragility of life
because there's nothing that's
sufficiently terrifying as realization
of that absolute fragility and it's
necessary to be profoundly terrified
before you can be motivated to seek out
those things that are of the highest
value as a consequence of considering
these ideas for many years and
especially considering the role that
evil has played say in the 20th century
and also the role that suffering plays
in life I've asked myself deeply what
the purpose of life might be and it
seems to me that life requires virtue
and so then you might ask well what do I
mean by virtue and what I mean by virtue
is following whatever it is in your life
that manifests itself to you as
meaningful and right and there's
codicils to that for example in order to
determine clearly what's meaningful and
right you have to stop light because if
you lie to yourself or you lie to other
people you blind yourself and then the
things that might appear to you is
meaningful are no longer trustworthy
because you're using an instrument that
you voluntarily damage to perceive
reality and that will lead you astray
and virtue requires what requires
humility because you have to stop
thinking that you know and so humility
and honesty are absolute preconditions
courage as well as necessary because
you'll have to learn to come to terms
with your own capacity for anxiety and
dread and aggression and and even your
capacity for well for terrible acts and
to continually set yourself right is to
walk down the path I believe of moral
virtue I would contrast the difference
Queen having happiness as a desirable
thing which it's incredibly desirable to
be happy but what I like to talk about
is thinking about this as a compass it
would provide a navigator of which
direction to go into it doesn't tell
them what direction it says here's the
direction that you're facing if
happiness is your compass to navigate
through the complexities and ambiguities
of life it means when something is
negative or problematic that's the wrong
direction to move into when it's your
values become your compass it's very
different let me give you example so one
of my fundamental values I have twin
four-year-old girls is to try to be a
good father and instill good values in
them and try to cultivate their
strengths and so when I'm faced with
conflicts which we all are faced with I
love writing I love doing science I love
teaching and I'm in the middle of a
great writing session eight hours I'm in
flow of the words just spilling out of
my brain onto the page and I look at the
clock and I realize it's almost time for
their bedtime I've got a conflict here
do I continue with this incredible
writing session or do I make sure I've
seen my kids before I go to sleep read
them a story tuck them in show them some
affection and maybe come back to this
and my writing might not be as good
afterwards knowing that my values are -
trying to be a good father and instill
values in them helps me with the
decision and helps me decide if you know
I'm going to go home spend some time my
children come back to my work if
happiness is my objective it leaves me
in a much bigger quandary of all these
conflicts of what do I do with the
limited amount of time and energy I have
in any given day and all these competing
things that are fighting for my
attention meaning and purpose in life
and values is a very stable compass this
is a way to create a life to feel good
about who we are to have an
understanding of what type of person we
want to be and try to close the gap
between what we do and what we strive to
become I want to make my personal
signature on my work so that I
leave the world a little bit of a better
place
there's an old idea deeply embedded
again in Western religious thinking that
reality is in some sense incomplete
unfinished or broken and that the role
of the human being is to complete it to
perfect it to finish it and see the idea
that reality is in some sense unfinished
and hence it's tragic and incomplete
manner and that the role of the human
being is in some sense to participate in
its perfection is a concept that is so
profound that it makes happiness as a
concept designed to encapsulate the
meaning of life so shallow that it
instantly becomes virtually negligible
we have a hypothesis here that the
purpose of conscious being is for those
beings who are conscious to transcend
their mortal limitations and to work for
the perfection of all that exists as a
goal that justifies suffering that's
unbeatable I think because what it does
is broaden and deepen your life in a
manner that you might compare to the
difference between elevator music and a
Beethoven symphony it's not that the
symphony is in any sense happier than
the music in fact quite the contrary but
it's deeper and more profound and richer
and incorporates more and justifies
itself more and that's the right
metaphor for life not happiness but but
depth and and and differentiated quality
and profundity to match the profundity
of the necessity of suffering
you
today on ideas say no to happiness by
CDC producer Frank Falk
you heard interviews with Gretchen Rubin
author of The Happiness Project Jordan
Peterson professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto dan polish author
of talking about God explaining the
meaning of religious life with
Kierkegaard Buber Tillich and Hetzel and
Todd Caston associate professor of
psychology at George Mason University in
Virginia our our Associate Producer is
Liz Nagy technical production by day
field to find out about upcoming ideas
programs and podcasts sign up for our
weekly online newsletter just go to our
website at CBC CA / ideas and follow the
links the executive producer of ideas is
Bernie look and I'm Paul Kennedy stay
tuned now for the hourly news on CBC
Radio One and on Sirius satellite radio
you